what is going on with brexit how close
are we to a deal well look we've clearly
made some progress in recent weeks and
days and it's really important to get
this fixed we know that the Northern
Ireland protocol has created real
challenges for businesses across all
communities in Northern Ireland it's
posing a challenge to the Good Friday
agreement and in fact the Integrity of
the UK so I think the Prime Minister the
foreign secretary in the online sector
have been hard at it and if we can make
some of those changes which we've been
pushing for to get a shift away for
example in trade in goods from GB from
Britain to Northern Ireland from having
checks and declarations on individual
Consignments towards a more
intelligence-based approach to controls
if we can encourage the EU to rely more
on Market surveillance than those checks
Market surveillance particularly in the
Republic to protect the EU single Market
that would if we can get that kind of
deal across the line Mark a paradigm
shift in the approach and will be very
good news to the communities in Northern
Ireland and I think for the Good Friday
agreement as well so you said that
there's been progress in weeks and days
it's effectively there right are we
talking about Monday could it be as soon
as tomorrow well you and I've been
discussing brexit for years now and uh
we always say there's no deal until
you've got the whole deal so I don't
want to get ahead of ourselves but is
that is that is that possibility it
could be tomorrow I think there's real
progress we want to make sure all the
pieces are in place but I think uh
hopefully there'll be good news uh in a
matter of days not not weeks and again
as I say this would be critically
important it would be a major
achievement uh by this prime minister
and all those involved but also Mark and
pay tribute to the efforts of those that
went before but if we can get this
resolved for the people of Northern
Ireland for the businesses for the
communities and frankly uh the manifesto
place we made really to thoroughly
properly fully get brexit done to be a
major achievement
um now there's obviously lots of
speculation going on about what's in the
deal can you give us a bit of a sense I
mean you've already sort of touched on a
few things there are we talking about
like a green light system for example
the goods that are going to remain in
Northern Ireland and then a red light
system for one sort of go to the EU is
that right look I think the trading
goods between Britain and Northern
Ireland is critical and if we can get
away from Individual checks in the
northern Irish reports and points of
arrival and encourage more of an
intelligence-based approach so is the
green light is that is that roughly the
right area those are the kinds of things
I mean it's well known uh that we've
been pushing for and again encouraging
the EU to look at Market surveillance
which basically means where they're
worried about Goods arriving in Northern
Ireland then going into the rest of the
EU including the Republic of Ireland and
posing a threat to the single Market
they keep an eye on that they monitor
that through the stores the shops in the
Republic and the rest of the EU how
about the role of the ecj the European
court of justice this is a big red line
isn't it for some people in your own
party and also the dep well look there's
a number of other things and I can't
divulge all the detail not least because
we want to make sure we get the whole
deal done but what I would say is if we
can scale back some of the regulatory
checks that apply and some of the
paperwork that applies that would in
itself involve a significant a
substantial scaling back of the role of
the ecj and of course Sophie the other
thing you'll know is this sense that in
the irreducible core areas where the EU
insist that EU rules uh need to apply to
protect the Integrity of the single
Market we need to make sure there are
any new rules in the future there's a
proper Democratic check and a proper
Democratic check coming out of the
institutions in Stormont that's
interesting so basically if there are
new EU rules that there should be a way
for Northern Ireland to have it say in a
way over the rules that can affect them
well that must be right in any
Democratic Arrangement and certainly in
relation to that I think we would
envisage that that check would be the
last word will be with the Democratic
institutions obviously the UK government
would have a role and there will be no
role for the ecj and something like that
now you said that me and you spoke about
brexit before we have for years right
like anyone else in Westminster and I
have to say you know you guys obviously
think that you got some significant
concessions out of the EU but this is
about politics as well isn't it and I
just wonder is there an accusation that
Rishi sunak has been a bit politically
naive at not getting the DP on side
already not getting the European
research group if you're a skeptic
conservatives on side as well these are
the people you need here to get anything
over the line well look I was brexit
secretary back in 2018. I've watched it
the one thing I'd say is you've got to
be very careful to bring people on board
at the right stage not to divulge the
details not to have if you like pressure
tactics on all sides and I'd say that
without aspersion on anyone
um what what the Prime Minister and the
government would be judged by is what we
deliver and you're not going to deliver
unless you get people on side you say
that you don't want to divorce the
details but look we know how this ends
ask Theresa May you can think you've got
a great deal let's see if the dep don't
come on side let's see Mike you're
living under a cave you know he must
know how these things work no I think
what Rishi uh and it was cleverly and
Christine Harris have done is very
quietly but doggedly pursue the changes
we need that will have our hope I
believe the support of people going
forward and it will be a massive
achievement if we can get that deal over
life but frankly the the media
speculation you're doing your job so can
I take to understand it but Richard has
written in the Sunday newspapers talking
about the deal hasn't he and he's been
very careful to set up the objectives
but also that we uh we're not there yet
um but we're obviously in a position
where uh we're close to on the cusp of a
deal and I think if we can get that deal
over the line it will be you think you
can are you confident I'm reasonably
confident we won't be talking about it
if we didn't think that there was a good
momentum uh some pragmatism that we
haven't seen before from the EU side but
we've got to get all the pieces in place
but it would Mark A a great deal for
Northern Ireland would protect the
Integrity of the United Kingdom and we
would fulfill our Manifesto will there
be a vote will there be a vote on the
deal in house Commons look let me allow
the government to set all of the details
out in uh in the proper way
um but I think in inevitably Parliament
will find a way to have it say
that doesn't sound
you are going to hold a boat no I'm
going to just what I don't want to do
Sophie is diverse details bit by bit
trip drip trip um but Parliament I mean
it doesn't sound like you want to answer
that question if there's going to be
votes give you a sense of the direction
of travel
um but of course we've got to get the
deal at the international level signed
uh and and agreed and make sure that the
arrangements that underpin it are to the
extent that they would require
legislation they would have to go
through the House of Commons if there
isn't a vote on the deal they'll be
uproar on your benches back there we
want to handle this properly
um and uh and you know and in the right
way and I think one thing we've learned
with meaningful votes and various other
things since
um uh 2016 and Beyond is that you have
to carry part with you and I'm confident
we would be able to okay
over the weekend that the eu's Ashley
Wonderland was to meet with King Charles
yesterday now that didn't happen for
operational reasons we're told but can
you see how you know right as brexit
negotiations come to a head that could
be seen as dragging the monarchy into
politics well the the the the the king
the Monarch uh regularly meets heads of
states and heads of leading
international organizations
um the precise timing of it and the
scheduling it actually is for the palace
and for the monarchy to decide it's not
something that we would impinge on but
look the um but it is actually a pretty
uh part of the normal functions of the
king would be to meet senior
International figures okay I want to
talk to to you a little bit about Boris
Johnson yeah he's told Sky News this
week that the best way forward was his
Northern Ireland's protocol bill has he
been lobbying against this deal
he has not been me against this deal but
look I would pay tribute to what Boris
did in relation to the ni legislation
because I do think it is reinforced our
hand in these negotiations the
government's position was under Boris
but also under Richardson act that in
the last resort we would be willing to
unilaterally legislate
um and I think that's helped I would
also say having been involved in both
governments that that pushing through
the legislation you know actually
without a deal with the EU was fraught
with legal uncertainty
um because ultimately we'd be legally
challenged including an arbitration
including arbitration under the deal
that Boris and and previous governments
this is interesting isn't it because as
you say the Northern Ireland protocol
Bill effectively allows you to
unilaterally override in emergencies
yeah parts of the of the deal do you
think that would have been challenging
the courts effectively the ecj having a
role in it well I think inevitably it
would be legally challenged I think
actually this should have been the
arbitral tribunal if we've gone to
arbitration on that and and then you
don't know what the outcome would be you
could get fined you could win you could
win some of it not all of it so it is
definitely and I think successful
governments have taken the view that
actually and that's why Boris didn't
press forward right the way through with
the legislation at the time
um and the the ideal outcome is to get a
negotiated solution but but also I want
to be clear I think the legislation
having the legislation there ready to go
reinforce the negotiators hands and I
think it was important but now time to
move on from it
well look if you get a negotiated
solution you don't need to proceed with
the legislation unilaterally okay now
I've done an awful lot about brexit um
you are under investigation for alleged
bullying of civil servants do you have
any idea when the findings of that
investigation are going to be due
well first of all Sophie as you know
I've said that I behave professionally
throughout but I also when the
complaints were made called for an
independent inquiry the Prime Minister
set one up it is for the independent
investigator Adam Tolley Casey to decide
all of that and I won't comment on it
further precisely because I want to
professionally respect the Integrity of
that process I understand of course that
you feel that you don't want to
Prejudice the outcome of the
investigation we of course won't get
into details of it for the same reason
but I just want to ask a couple of very
fast actual straightforward questions on
the timeline when were you first aware
that a complaint had been made so we
I've already said this to the House of
Commons the first time any complaint was
I was notified was the day before in the
mid-november when the day before I did
pmqs because the times reported that the
first formal complaint was actually made
last March is that right so uh not to my
knowledge but Sophie I'm going to be
really careful about this uh I've said
to Adam Tully I've said I'm not going to
comment on it and I wanted to give you a
straight answer to a straight question
I'm not going to start getting into the
he said she said of the inquiry it's not
right for me to do so when was the first
conversation you had with Rishi sinak
about it
um I honestly can't remember but it
would not have been uh until the formal
complaint was made in mid-november so
that was after you were appointed to the
cabinet under Russia yes
um even though there is this letter at
the times has seen that suggests that
the first formal complaint was made last
March well look again not to your
knowledge what you're doing is inviting
me to comment on uh the what is actually
part of the subject matter of the
inquiry and I'm not going to do just the
timeline but I'm trying again I know but
it but it inevitably drags me into that
and look the uh Adam Tolley will conduct
this inquiry he's it's already obviously
ongoing and I'll answer as I said I
would all questions he's got and
there'll be a transparent report but
don't please don't um uh expect me to
answer questions now it wouldn't be
right for me to do so Jake Perry the
former chairman says you should stand
down while that investigation's ongoing
why haven't you done that well look I
think um first of all that's ultimately
for the prime minister's side but I
think actually just by lodging
complaints you can knock out a cabinet
minister or a senior figure I'm not sure
that's right we believe in innocent or
proven guilty in this country and uh
look I'll cooperate fully with the
inquiry and I'll respect the outcome of
it I don't think it's knocking out
though is it we're talking about
standing aside while some very serious
allegations by multiple people are being
investigated well if you believe in
innocent or proven guilty you wouldn't
want uh to penalize people until you've
got the outcome
um and I could see why that would
politicize the process of lodging
complaints because you can effectively
for months on end get remove cabinet
members or other leading political
figures if the complaint is that
Powerball will you resign I'm not going
to start speculating on what the outcome
might be again you're asking me to
comment on the subject matter I'm not
asking you to come up with a project
myself I'm asking you to find out what
what you will do but it's a hypothetical
question so I've got two different
outcomes well
allow me to respond in the right uh way
at the right time of course look if an
allegation of bullying is upheld I would
reside
thank you uh right now let's talk a
little bit about the brief that you uh
are continuing with Ministry of Justice
uh brief so you're announcing today that
transgender women who've committed
violent all sexual offenses will no
longer be able to be held in mainstream
women's prisons talk to me about that
announcement and what's going to do well
we want to have a liberal sensitive
tolerant approach to the LGBT community
as a whole and in particular trans uh
the trans Community who suffer a lot in
this country and have high levels of
challenges for example mental health
bullying and things like that so I want
to be clear about that
um equally we need to protect the most
vulnerable in our society and I think
where you've got uh trans offenders
trans women offenders and the suggestion
is or the question is whether they move
into the uh the female prison State I
think we need to be really clear about
protecting uh the other female offenders
prisoners in that estate so we're very
clear that from next week we will
introduce new rules which means that any
trans offender with a male genitalia
intact or who have been convicted of a
sexual offense and I'm adding to that if
they've been convicted of a violent
offense they will not be allowed into
the female prison estate now this comes
after the case of Isla Bryson and
Scotland who's a trans woman convicted
of two rapes
is Isle of Brighton a man or a woman
look I I think it's
um very clear that she's not a woman in
the sense that I've defined it but
that's for the Scottish authorities in
this in the English and Welsh prison
State she would not be allowed into the
female estate by the way just one point
of correction I introduced these changes
a while ago the reason they're coming
into force on Monday is because the time
taken to do it very carefully and
assiduously I want to talk a little bit
about the courts backlog as well sure
this is a huge huge issue under your
department and it was causing frankly
misery for you know so many people who
are waiting and unacceptably long amount
of time to have their Justice heard and
I think we can have a quick look at the
number of defendants awaiting uh trial
this is the backlog the number of people
waiting for unsentencing and you can see
it's effectively flatlining if
increasing slightly it's certainly not
coming down and for the first time rape
victims are now facing a typical delay
of more than three years for their case
become completed in court this is the
rape case waiting time which to be
honest I find quite extraordinary uh
really how is this in any way acceptable
so on three points first of all actually
the we were getting the backlog down of
course the backlog was caused by the
pandemic because the uh the rules meant
that you couldn't have jury trials uh
because the social distancing rules it's
not it's not coming down though isn't it
hold on so it was starting to come down
we made great progress then we had the
CBA strike it went back up it is now
stabilizing and coming down not as fast
as I would have liked it which is why
we're working with the courts we've
reviewed and renewed the Nightingale
course look at the backlog again please
just
to get that graph up again if possible
the latest data I
went down it is so not by a huge amount
yet but actually if you look at this
these are the MOJ figures can you just
explain to me am I being really stupid
here because it doesn't look like it's
coming down well actually I think if you
look at the December versus November
figure uh we've gone po right
yeah we're going past the peak it is
starting to stabilize it's coming down
uh not by uh enough and that's why we're
taking all the other measures that I
refer to with the Nightingale courts
with the removal of the uh limit on
sitting days
and in relation to rape
um you're absolutely right that those
cases are particularly challenging in
fact I can tell you that we've seen uh
almost a doubling since 2019 but
actually the progress has been more
recent as well since 2019 we've seen a
doubling of the number in both cases
what is the number sorry let me let me
tell you but just because I've seen this
before the doubling of rate cases and
that's not what I said um so let me
answer the question because this is so
sensitive and it's so important we've
doubled the number of cases referred uh
to by the police the CPS we've also seen
a doubling of the number of CPS charges
and they're doubling also of the Crown
Court receipts in the last year alone
rape convictions the volume have gone up
by two-thirds and can we talk in wrong
numbers because I think the the problem
is if you say the doubling it sounds oh
wow that's great but if you're doubling
from like 0.9 to 1.8 of rape uh reports
ending a conviction then that's hardly
any is it but actually the conviction
rate I think it's gone up to
um 69 but you have to be careful the
conviction rate was properly by the CPS
is measured cases that come to court and
that result in a conviction but look
with Restless to do more so if I don't
want to give you false impression we
want to do much much more which is why I
introduced 24 7 rape support line which
is why I'm quadrupling the support for
victims compared to 2010 when labor will
last in office we've got this operation
satyria prosecutors and police operating
much more uh hand in glove together and
I also introduced section 28
pre-recorded uh evidence for the victims
the complainants in rape cases so that
they can do so without the glare of a
courtroom we're making progress but
there is still much much more to do yeah
and my understanding is I think it's
still if you report a rape chance of you
seeing you know a conviction is still I
think less than two percent and I would
also just go back to the original
question is it acceptable that a typical
rape case is now you have to wait three
years for that to come to trial well no
we want to get that number down clearly
and critically if you come forward and
of course it's incredibly difficult not
just to be the victim then to come and
face the whole process of the criminal
justice system and what we want to do is
encourage victims and complainants to
stay with the process the two big things
is the expansion of independent uh
sexual violence advisors and we know
that we've got a much better chance of
securing convictions if the victims get
that support early and the 24 7 rape
support line also means they get the
right support as early as possible we've
got much more to do but again I come
back to the key thing which is over the
last year the volume of convictions has
risen by two-thirds more to do but we're
heading back in the right direction
after covert okay thank you very much